Like a boss. Kenny was, let's
talk some F1 action. Did anybody,
did you watch the Australian grampy
grampy Grand Prix down in Melbourne,
Australia? Uh,
it was a great fucking race and it
lived up to the hype that this year the
Ferrari's we're going to be going, I've
only watched this sport for one season,
so I don't know shit about it all.
I knows last year it was all about
the Mercedes team, Lewis Hamilton,
Nico Rosberg, you know, they had
the whole days of thunder. You know,
I'm the guy who's been around
the block on the other fucking,
I'm the Tom Cruise Guy,
somebody fucking Robert
Duvall and everybody else,
which is watching last year. And if
those two guys didn't hate each other,
it would have been fucking boring as
shit because basically every race was a
race to the first corner.
Whoever got there first was just driving
through clean air and the cars was so
equally matched. Nobody
could catch up with somebody.
You basically had to fuck
up where your car died. Um,
so all the exciting racing was
for like funeral fourth, fifth,
sixth place or whatever. Three cycles
going after it for the last, you know,
championship point is they say, you know,
back in 10th place that was exciting.
But up front it was just Lewis Hamilton
or Nico Rosberg just just doing laps
was, you know, Kinda got a little boring.
So this year they were
talking about how um,
Ferrari was very quiet,
eerily quiet during the off season working
on their [inaudible] suspension and
the engine and all that type of
shit with the new regulations,
whatever the fuck they are.
I don't know what they are.
Uh, the ties are 25%
wider than last year then
that they were going to make
a serious challenge for, uh,
against Mercedes issue.
So the fucking race starts
and a, the Australia Dude, I already
forget his name. Rico Rican Berg.
I have no fucking idea.
Like eventually I'll, I'll,
I'll get these people's names.
Style Ricky rocket, I forget. Okay.
Everybody wanted him to
win. The poor bastard.
He's down there and they're
taken like the, the,
the warmup lap or whatever. And uh,
not even a warmup lap.
They just going around and getting
ready to get into positions.
Just to do the warmup lap and
his car gets stuck in sixth gear.
I think there's a, an
electronic sensor issue, um,
that it's stuck in sixth year.
So if it can be cleared with a reset,
we've all been there, right?
The side of the highway,
except he's got 100,000
people in a fucking zillion
millions of fans around the
world watching this shit.
So they got to push his car and they got
to take out the fucking transmission in
like five minutes, throw
a new one in there,
try and get it back in the fucking car
before the race starts. That alone,
if they just showed that,
that would've been amazing.
They can't kept cutting back to
it. I wish they showed more of it.
A long story short, he wasn't able to
get out there until, uh, the second lap.
He was already two laps down.
So that kind of sucked for all the
Australian fans and uh, then his car shit,
the bed halfway through the race,
however, so the race fucking starts.
All right.
I think Lewis Hamilton had the
pole and then Sebastian Vettel, um,
for Ferrari was in second place and uh,
Louis had a great start and he was out
front and I go, wow, I guess that's it.
I guess the Mercedes are
gonna win it this year, right.
So they get about 20 laps
in and Lewis Hamilton pits,
it's one of these races,
it's like 57 laps.
And the announcers were saying that they
were going to pit one time and it's all
when you pit and blah,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
So all this shit is
becoming fascinating to me.
So Lewis Hamilton goes into Pitt,
right? Sebastian Vettel was,
I don't know how far behind,
a couple seconds behind he
decides to stay out there.
So the whole time when Louis
was out there in first place,
Sebastian's behind him. All right.
So Lewis is driving in the clean air.
It's like, you know, if you were on
a fucking on a lake and you bring,
it's just still water. You could,
you could go way faster and your boat as
opposed to if the water was all fucking
choppy, you got to go slower than,
it's the same thing except it to,
it's with air. I'm just saying
this for everybody else out there.
Who's dumb like me in the fact that air
is invisible, you don't understand it.
So no matter what this guy's
doing, Sebastian Vettel,
he can only get so close to a,
to Louis Hamilton because all
the air coming off of him,
and I guess the tires are bigger this
year, which causes more turbulence.
It would actually, it,
he's going to use more fuel and chew up
more of his tires if he gets too close
to him, which is really fucking, I dunno,
I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing.
So Hamilton was having problems
with the tire. He pits early
and it's the soft tire for Mercedes.
So it starts to cool off down here.
It can fill it.
So the Ferrari team takes a
gamble and says, fuck this.
We're gonna stay out there.
So Sebastian now is in first
place driving into clean air.
He's got the nice smooth lake,
he's bringing the boat across except
it's a car and it's going through air.
You still with me and he stays
out there for one lap and they go,
he's definitely going to come in
for the second lap. Meanwhile, um,
Louis Hamilton came right back out
of the pits and then was you know,
technically in fourth
place but he's, you know,
but he already pitted the other two
guys in front of them have to pit and so
does the other guy.
So technically it's like he's still in
first place but now he's driving in dirty
air back there. So Sebastian's
flying around the track,
he goes around a second time and you
know the tires are getting chewed up.
He's driving like a fucking maniac and
then he comes around a third time and
then like he's not gonna, he's not
going to fucking stay out there.
He stayed out there again,
Hamilton losing time on this lab.
Bet on you. Imagine not losing time,
but he is going to lose time if
he carries on and doesn't a pit.
And guess what Ferrari
have left him out. And
now basically it was like this was the
most exciting part of a consistent to
fucking race. So basically
what he's trying to do,
he's trying to get out so far ahead
that he has time to pit when he goes in,
get his tires and get back out on
the track in front of fucking uh,
Louis Hamilton. It was like a fucking
movie. He pulls in his fourth time around
Zen. So we're Ferrari
just waiting for that gap.
They fucking take the tires. You've
got to go so fucking slow too.
Now he got to slow down to like,
like you're driving a
Prius when you're in there.
And as he's slowing down this
show and Lewis is coming around,
he's coming around, he's coming
around, he gets the tires,
fucking Sebastian's coming out.
It's like a fucking action movie.
And it was literally, he just,
Sebastian's battle comes in
to stop now. Lewis Hamilton,
is that the penultimate quarter? But
Sebastien panel's going to come out,
I guess walk surpassed bevel
now ahead. Oh, blue is Hamilton.
How about so behind for stepping or
we've got federal Vistaprint. Hamilton,
Sebastian for Ferrari.
Just get out in front of Louis
Hamilton and then that was the race.
You saw the Mercedes guy slammed his
hand down on the guy in the pits,
right? The head fucking guy, right?
The guy goes the eyes wide shut illuminati
parties at the end of the fucking
race right there. Probably on
some yacht that's like invisible,
like the air that they
drive through. Right.
He fucking slammed his hand down like
medium and then fucking slammed it down a
second time. Right. Then I was like,
this guy knows that this fucking
race is over. And that was it.
Ferrari won the first race.
So does Jim Federal starts off 2017
by winning the Australian grown play,
you know, backing up
their lack of shit talk.
They were real quiet in the off season.
So, uh, I was actually really, you know,
I like way my, I'm one of
those guys, I like both,
both team proceedings and Ferrari. I mean,
I don't know how you'd get mad at either
one of them. The fucking beautiful,
amazing cars that they've built all
this fucking, uh, over the years.
So I'm just happy that this seems like
there's going to be competition and if it
can be as exciting as that,
um, for the whole season,
uh, I think, um, maybe some more you
guys can get into it. Like I did,
I believe the next races
in China, in Indochino,
in China. Um, that's going to
be the next one. But I was,
I was thrilled with the race. Um,
I don't know how many F1
fans listen to this shit. Uh,
I'd love to hear your thoughts on it.
It was a great race. I enjoyed it a
lot. Thank you. Thank you very much.
The basketball,
all that wraps it up for our first
round in the Australian grumpy here in
Melbourne. See everyone in two weeks
time in Shanghai, in China for round two.
Thank you very much.